[Applause]
[Music]
used to love me
now you want me to suck on finish
there was a time when I made it after
uni but now Michael is are used to be
the Clown Prince of college a brain that
your lab and they you kids don't
understand why your parents like they're
still kinda hit miss I feel but if you
happy but the water boys saw Nikki
socked robots made you throw up public
meet both Lisa and Jack and Jill the
cinematic die thing on your dare I did a
few serious fear didn't get the but you
thought I was okay but I rather stick to
crappy flaws that were popular in ninety
years
tell me you recognize any of these
rookie underdog meets a hot attractive
babe but some hot bunny bullies trying
to stop my goofy ways my quirky sidekick
and her grandma help me on my
while using an annoying noise and drop
the papaya come on guys you liked it the
first eighteen times surely you like it
56 line what the hell happened today I
make you laugh when you're I and 1990
now you treat me like I turn
get Rob Schneider worm hey thanks buddy
but you forgot to put me in pixels
well that's because you Lin do blackface
for me seriously Sandler even I have
standard
[Music]
I don't know why I've angered all of you
he's got saved me or to Transylvania - I
do the same thing that I've been doing
for years
so what does change now who gives me all
these
[Music]
no don't you see even your idiot
characters from the past figured it out
your audience has thrown up though you
yourself have not grown up they talk
about doing a lot of it your audience
have discovered new things so you must
discover new things evolve your craft
try something different user movies more
than just an excuse to go on vacation I
mean we'll get your latest publicity
photo given you're sick of you try again
I see what you're saying I should be
even more predictable oh no whore on
funny I definitely didn't say that even
racially insensitive Christ I'm just
gonna sit down by Rob Schneider can you
do reference can I